hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast pathologists perspective
limitations and benefits of muna
fixation and immuno typing for
monoclonal gammopathy characterization
it is presented by Daniel L heard MD we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
herbs and sponsored by Sevilla Sevilla
is the world's leading provider of
clinical protein electrophoresis
equipment and the agents a technology
used for in vitro diagnostic testing its
systems analyze proteins to screen and
monitor various diseases and conditions
these include oncology multiple myeloma
metabolic disorders such as diabetes and
also hemoglobinopathies and rare
pathologies Tourneur valve sabia please
visit www.sedar.com I'm Julia Roberts
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before you again I
would like to remind everyone this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and timing on
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen what answers and
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice you'll be viewing a presentation
in a slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. hood dr. hood joined these
staff of Miami Valley Hospital a 750
then tertiary care hospital in 1990 in
complement clinical labs original
records lab in Dayton Ohio since 1997 he
has been medical director of the
clinical
at Miami Valley Hospital and the CCL lab
during his career he has been on the
boards of Miami Valley Hospital premier
health hospital system Community Blood
Center community tissue services the
Ohio Society of pathologists and joint
restoration foundation he's also served
as the system pathology chair for the
premier health hospital system over five
years ago dr. hood transitioned the labs
protein electrophoresis from gel based
to capillary zone electrophoresis his
complete bio is found on the lab routes
website please join me in welcoming dr.
hood I will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you Judy this afternoon I'd like
to give our experience and our views on
the differences and the benefits and
limitations of the two common
technologies used today and
characterizing monoclonal gammopathy x'
the two technologies immuno typing
immuno fixation are similar but
different and we'll highlight those
during the course of the discussion
today a little bit of background on our
practice confident clinical labs is a
regional reference laboratory based in
southwest Ohio we're responsible for
taking the reference work for all five
of the hospitals within the premier
health system along with multiple other
hospitals outside our system as well as
numerous physician offices and this
includes the bulk of the hematology
oncology practices in Dayton and
Southwest Ohio we adopted the capillary
technology in 2007 and when I went to
our tacks and I said when do you think
we took this technology on I got dates
that ranged from 2001 to 2011 we
actually had to check with our sales
representative to get the exact date so
we were earlier adopters of this type of
technology our current volumes over the
last 12 months and these volumes are
increasing we've done almost 11,000
serum protein electrophoresis and almost
5,000 em you know typing cases in the
last
12 months I checked with our
technologist this morning today we will
be doing 68 serum protein
electrophoresis and 26 amino typing
cases alone now it's important to
understand what we are not we are not an
academic center we do not have
affiliation with a medical school we do
take on medical technologist but we are
not a research facility I'd like to talk
a little bit about the evolution of
characterization of monoclonal proteins
and by the fact that I'm showing this
slide indicates my eight
this is immuno electrophoresis I imagine
the vast majority of people out there
never had to endure this type of
technology so for Christmas is here for
historical purposes the key phrase that
I was taught as a resident was looking
for matching distortions in this myriad
of protein bands this is very
labor-intensive process
it was slow you're doing one patient per
gel thankfully that was replaced by Mena
fixation which came out in the late 80s
and was adapted to adopted over the
early 90s this technique was much easier
than immuno electrophoresis it was
faster than mu no electrophoresis you
could batch patients and run multiple
patients on a gel and it was much more
sensitive than mu no electrophoresis the
next step in our evolution there was
immuno typing this is an example of
these typical six screen that you will
see with immuno typing and I would just
like to point out a couple of features
here there is a dilution set where you
can set it for hyper hypo or standard
dilution the technologist will do this
based on the SPE results there is also a
magnification function where you can
change the mag
vacation of the gel so this is a
standard 1x and we'll look in multiple
cases over the course of the discussion
where we go up to a 2x into a 4x
appearance so in 2007 we adopted Capitol
Arizona electrophoresis for serum
protein electrophoresis and immuno
typing for determination of the type of
monoclonal gammopathy now from our
perspective this was very advantageous
because the process is much more
automated if you're a larger volume
laboratory this is a great benefit the
68 serum protein electrophoresis that my
tech is running today were completed an
hour this morning
it has a fire-and-forget technology I
would say for immuno typing you can run
eight samples in an hour so you get a
decent volume through this the other
thing is because you're not on a gel you
don't need to batch I remember the old
days with our earlier gel technologies
if you had an extra patient beyond the
capabilities of your gel you're a little
reticent about breaking out another gel
just to run those one or two patients
with i.t that's not an issue you can run
as many patients or as few patients as
you want during the day because it's
just a one-and-done process for it so
when you made the transition I'd like to
start off with saying pathologist mourn
the loss of the physical job it's like
you have to go through the five stages
of mourning from kubler-ross all
pathologists that I've trained with like
to hold the gel Bend it under the light
put it on a magnifying tray shine light
from underneath it to look at there
there was a an intimacy with the gel
that's gone with em you know typing it's
all done off the computer screen so that
that physical contact is gone now
because we were early adopters
we ran gel immuno fixation with the
immuno typing for three straight months
that was to get ourselves a very high
level of familiar
with the technology see were there
pluses and minuses were never the
technology but with ourselves
currently the sabia in 2012 introduced a
training program that they will load
onto your computer system so you really
don't have to go through this
three-month process like we did in that
three months with our determination no
one else's and we've actually loaded
that training program onto our computer
as we get newer pathologists than our
around group well we use that to help
train them to read this type of
technology and it's also important to
note we did not get rid of our gel
system entirely we still use the gel we
use it for urines and you're an immuno
fixation and for some cases of serum
where we're just not quite sure about
the immuno typing results so since I
mentioned that we kept the gel when do I
go back to jail when I have a nightie
result first most commonly is when I get
a very very small indistinctive bump and
this is usually on the first time
specimen for a patient it's just kind of
a blanket I can hold on to if I get a
result off an immuno fixation I'll run
it when I do have prior results that
dope do not match current results so for
me that's just a quality check all ago
clonal bands I prefer to use the gel in
that instance though it's not required
I've called all ago clonal patterns off
the eye T probably one of the most
common situations and it's really not
that common at all is when we detect
free light chains on em you know typing
but we don't have a matching heavy chain
abnormality because the immuno typing
does not have heavy chains D or E
available we reflux over to a gel immuno
fixation in these cases and overall less
than 5% of our cases are referred to a
gel for typing some general
guidelines for reading IT you can have
there is a standard serum protein
electrophoresis that's run with each
sample you can overlay that with each of
the areas of the immuno typing or you
can read it without most folks prefer to
read with the overlay of the spe and
i'll show examples of this as we go
along
I initially scan at the one X in other
words no magnification I do that so I
can see if there's any problems with the
immuno typing every now and then
there'll be an issue with a capillary
and we'll have to repeat a sample and at
one X that's just the quickest and
easiest way to see that in most
instances I use a 2x or 4x magnification
at 2x you can see everything from alpha
1 all the way through the gamma at 4 X
you can see beta 1 beta 2 and gamma all
in one field and those appear to be the
most useful for my practice I generally
do not like going over 4 X like went to
an 8 X or 16x9 education because that's
a little too close it's I'm making
things up that really aren't there so I
like to stay back a little bit from that
and a key part is when you're looking at
immuno typing you're looking at not only
what is removed but what remains behind
to help you make the diagnosis and we'll
take a look at that in some of the cases
and we're going through and I want to
stress that all the cases that are shown
here are cases from our laboratory these
were none not cases provided by any
other laboratory we always want to
control whether we're running the gel or
running the IT and if you look here is
the serum protein electrophoresis at
this end then you have that you go you
have G a M
kappa and lambda add it to each of the
tubes and you get a binding of these
antisera to the proteins they are then
removed away from the peaks so we're
looking at this case we can see the
farthest peak here was IgG and it's
corresponding light chain was lambda we
can see the next peak was IgM again with
a corresponding lambda and the final
peak was IgA with a corresponding Kappa
and then you can look up at the gel
above and see the matching
correspondence the G lambda the M lambda
and the a Kappa a normal patient and
invariably when people look at their
first normal patient on here their
answer is this is monoclonal i GG Kappa
but when you look at it here's our SPE
lay with no abnormal Peaks here's the G
and you can see there's a large loss of
G right here but this is poly this loss
here is polyclonal G likewise there's a
large loss of polyclonal Kappa here with
a smaller loss of polyclonal lambda
smaller losses of a and M also occur
as the corresponding gel for this
patient showing the classic broad fuzzy
bands we've seen on a normal patient
this is a normal peak but the addition
here is we have a polyclonal a pattern
right there and there is equal
two-thirds loss of Kappa 1/3 loss of
lambda in the G region so this is a
polyclonal a pattern the next common
pattern we see is just a hyper gamma
cloud in the Nima pattern and here you
have large loss of IgG smaller loss of
IgA 2/3 loss of Kappa 1/3 loss of lambda
a classic polyclonal pattern and again
the corresponding gel pattern that were
used to seeing now this is a case of a
by claudel with and without the
superimposition of the electrophoresis
the ser protein electrophoresis so here
we've got the by clonal peak we're not
doing the overlay with the IgG we lose
one of the peaks with IgA we lose
neither of the peaks within we lose a
peak with both Kappa and lambda we lose
a peak but without the overlay it's a
little difficult to see what exactly was
lost so we include the overlay with the
lighter color of line here we've lost
the IgG in this piece
we've lost the Kappa and the
corresponding peak so that's our G Kappa
the taller peak was lambda and I GM so
have an IgM lambda and an IgG Kappa
pattern
this again is a 1x these Peaks are large
enough that a magnification really isn't
necessary and here is the corresponding
gel showing the G Kappa and M lambda
Peaks this is a case for the 2x
magnification
we've lost the albumen it's out of the
field here's the electrophoresis pattern
here on the upper left we have the G
here which shows very little loss almost
complete loss of a no loss an M little
loss in lambda but a matching loss
between the a and the Kappa so this is a
case of monoclonal i g IG a Kappa when
our gamma region and this is the same
case done on gel now I want to be sure
that people understand when I had these
gels run it was strictly for purposes of
this talk I did not feel any of the gels
to interpret any of these cases now this
is a case and I apologize I should have
done this at 2x rather than 1 X so again
in the upper left hand corner we have
the standard electrophoresis here
followed then by the G
in Kappa lambda as we progress through
the antibodies than what's important
here is in the beta one peak there is a
distortion that matches up in both the a
and lambda channels and this is where
you know that phrase matching distortion
that was used a long long time ago with
regard to immune electrophoresis
actually comes into play again with this
technology and it will have to admit
that actually having trained as a
resident on immuno electrophoresis
helped me adapt to this technology as an
attending physician and then here is the
corresponding gel with the obvious IgA
lambda bands here and here I will say
that at higher magnification that
distortion is much much easier to see
this is an instance of a small IgM Kappa
so in our electrophoresis the arrow
highlights a small peak that is present
in what we used to call fast gamma when
you look at both the IgG and IgA
channels that peak is still there when
you go to IgM the peak has disappeared
so this is an instance where seeing what
is retained such as the G and the a and
also then comparing again what has lost
the M helps guide the interpretation
then likewise go to the lambda channel
you can still see the corresponding bump
after the deletion of lambda so lambda
is still there we have a loss of the
bump and the Kappa channel after the
addition so this is an IgM Kappa
monoclonal protein and again the gel
highlighting the M and the Kappa now
this is a bit more of a more difficult
case and it can highlight some of the
fears people have about immuno typing
but with experience this becomes much
less of a challenge because you will
recognize that you need to do something
else will not just blow over this case I
also have to point out as I'm doing
these interpretations we have a cadre of
very experienced medical technologists
who do the initial protein and immuno
typing reads for all the pathologists so
each of these cases has at least two
sets of eyes looking at it and many of
these texts have been with me for over a
decade doing this and they're quite
quite excellent at this type of
technology so in this case on the
protein electrophoresis we've got this
little bump between the beta 2 and the
peak in the gamma region and when we do
the immuno typing not quite sure if G
goes away a does not go away M does not
go away it doesn't look like Kappa goes
away it looks like there bump is still
there
but it does look like the lambda band
has gone away so this is one of those
instances where we've got a small bump
small peak and we're curious as to what
specifically is going on in some
instances we can identify monoclonal
protein and some you cannot so we're
and did gel on this first thing which
you can see is we do have a distinct
lambda band the a band is too fuzzy I
don't believe that that was monoclonal
it also did not match the immuno
typing's that really wasn't my
consideration I was more worried about
the G band which is obviously polyclonal
as is the M and this isn't one of the
instances where I would automatically
reflux to gel because I have a light
chain only and so we will do ad in an e
heavy chain on a gel to see if it's an
IG D lambda or IG in lambda
monoclonal protein not all laboratories
will do this some laboratories may sign
this case out as lambda light chain you
know monoclonal lambda light chain
cannot exclude an IgE or IG d lambda
pair protein we prefer just to work
these up and remove all doubt so this is
one of the instances where we will
always run a gel within our laboratory
now this is a list of two examples of
what can be a problem but is not
necessarily a problem in immuno typing
it is an uncommon occurrence and the two
cases I'm going to show you or the only
two cases that I can recall running
across in this instance and the arrows
highlight out we had the obvious peak
here on our SPE when we look at G the
peak remains or you look at Kappa the
peak remains and when you look at lambda
the peak has gone away so very high
confidence level this is a lambda light
chain restore to pair protein but if you
notice a and M look virtually identical
with both having loss of the peak
this is a phenomenon known as Co
subtraction and this is an instance
where I would run a gel to confirm one
of the two heavy chains and in
particular this was a patient that was a
known IgM lambda and this is an instance
where my current results have didn't
exactly match my historical results so
we would go in and do a gel on this
patient and in this instance it's an
obvious IgM lambda by J's obviously
polyclonal this is a phenomena known as
Co subtraction and like I said this is
very uncommon here's another case we
have a fairly substantial polyclonal
peak here you have polyclonal loss of
IgA in this big group get a loss of
polyclonal Kappa and polyclonal lambda
here you've got a matching loss of IgA
and a matching loss of IgM along with a
loss of Kappa and you can make out right
here there's this small bump or a small
band that's what we used to call it on a
protein electrophoresis on gel between
the beta 2 and the gamma so again these
arrows highlight the areas of interest
with a circle on you know that IgA zone
when we gelled this we see that the
heavy chain was IgM now what's
interesting is the light chain is
indistinct in here because the
background polyclonal and this is an
instance where the gel from our
perspective was not as helpful in terms
of light chain determination as the i.t
was now there is a delusional setting
you can make in your instrument
to address the situation the instrument
has a hyper gamma standard and hypo
gamma dilution that it also has a fourth
dilution called optimizer and optimizer
is only to be used as a secondary method
in cases where you run into Co
subtraction if you run optimizer on this
case it would remove the need to run a
gel because that takes care of the issue
of Co subtraction and from our
perspective anytime you can avoid
running a gel it's to your advantage
because running a gel delays your case
by an additional day and as we are
familiar with gels have their problems
as well and one of them has to do with
application point issues and here in
this case you can see every channel as a
band showing up in the application zone
and you look at this
sure there's a monoclonal protein there
or not this is a case where you want to
treat it with the beta 2 mercaptoethanol
and when that's done you get the obvious
by GM Kappa in this case but without
that treatment you wouldn't be able to
see the band and again M you know typing
kind of removes the need for doing the
beta to mercaptoethanol in our
experience you're now going to go
through a series of cases without the
gel this used to show you how easy it is
to do these interpretations how we can
run through a standard day's work in a
timely fashion and how we don't really
need to be doing gel confirmations on
the vast vast majority of cases okay in
this case we have a prominent band in
the beta 2 region on the same protein
electrophoresis IgG is not subtracted
from this band though it is subtracted
from the polyclonal gene the gamma
fraction a isn't only minimally
subtracted in a polyclonal fashion as is
lambda but you can see a very clear loss
of IgM and a very clear loss of Kappa so
this case represented a monoclonal i GM
Kappa in the beta 2 region another
example here on the SPE we see this peak
in the what we used to call slow gamma
region and by immuno typing there is no
loss of M no
a-and the peak though in the beta-2
region there's the classic polyclonal
loss but both IgG and Kappa demonstrate
losses of that peak so this is an IgG
Kappa monoclonal now what's important to
notice also is there is a large
monoclonal component that was also
removed so here's your 1/3 loss lambda
and 2/3 loss Kappa for a classic
polyclonal pattern so this is a
monoclonal i GG Kappa superimposed on a
polyclonal background another example
again we have a prominent peak in the
gamma fraction on the IgG channel we
have loss of the peak you know the
lambda channel we have loss of the peak
the peak is retained in the other three
channels AM and Kappa but as in the
prior example there's also a background
polyclonal population demonstrated here
in the Tampa band here in the lambda and
again here in the G so this is another
example of a monoclonal IgG in this case
an IgG lambda superimposed on a
polyclonal background now as Peaks get
smaller you have to apply maybe some
additional activity in your brain to
make things work here we have a very
small peak in the mid gamma fraction
also you might notice at the alpha-1 and
alpha-2 regions are somewhat prominent
so this may be an ongoing acute phase
reaction so you may be thinking maybe
that's CRP maybe some immune complexes
when you do the immuno typing
it gets lost in the IgG it's kept in the
IgA and it's kept in the IgM then when
you look at Kappa the peak is kept
whereas in lambda the peak is lost so
this is an IgG lambda this is a small
IgG Lambda monoclonal protein another
example of a prominent beta to peak here
Cho's on the SPE Channel here then the
peak is lost in the IgG lost in the
Kappa retained in the other three
channels so this is a very simple and
easy IgG Kappa protein highlighted here
by the permanent arrows in the slide now
here's an example again of a small
monoclonal peak here's the distortion
you see an upward tick if we were just
doing the SPE we'd probably call this a
band of restricted mobility suspicious
for an in band and recommend immuno
typing but since we're doing the immuno
typing you can see the band in the SPD
it is kept in the a it is kept in the
lambda it's lost in the IgG and then we
go down to our light chains you can see
it is lost in the lambda but that bump
is kept right there in the Kappa so this
is an IgG Lambda monoclonal protein
this is one where I get to use my
favorite phrase of matching distortions
so here we have an instance on the SPE
where the beta 2 band looks a little
distorted it doesn't have its same
symmetry in a symmetry and your beta 1
and beta 2 Peaks is always a good clue
to go looking in those regions so we put
in the IgG or IgM it maintains that same
distorted look the subtraction though in
a and Kappa is identical so this is an
IgA cap of monoclonal protein in the
beta 2 region and I got to use my phrase
matching distortions so it's going to
bring this to an end method comparisons
between gel electrophoresis and
capillary zone electrophoresis the
purpose of the tests are identical we're
looking to characterize and detect
monoclonal proteins
both in serum and urine one of the
differences is the automation level gel
is semi automated there's a lot more
hands-on work done with those capillary
zone electrophoresis with capillary and
you know typing there's a fully
automated process I always like to use
the military term fire-and-forget you
load the instrument you let it run you
come back and do your interpretation
they will both use you know a GM cap and
landal antisera
for detection the main difference that I
mentioned earlier is that capillary zone
IT does not have a GED or IgE available
so if you want to look for those
particular monoclonal proteins you have
to reflect back to gel sensitivity
resolution are slightly different the
detection limit for gel electrophoresis
is better you can get a you can identify
a smaller peak of monoclonal protein be
part of the reason there is you know the
methodology itself when you're looking
at gel and you know fixation you're
adding something to identify the
protein you create this complex which
magnifies the presence of the band when
you're looking at capillary
electrophoresis and you know typing
you're subtracting so you don't get that
additional level of sensitivity however
the level sensitivity is quite good you
can go back and look at the C ap surveys
for instance and see the comparability
between the two based on resolution
capillary zone electrophoresis because
the higher voltages employed gives much
higher level of resolution I will say
that in your initial period that takes
also a little bit of getting used to
because lines that may have once been
very smooth right now may be a little
bumpy and you just have to train your
brain to realize and kind of smooth out
the bumps for yourself but again we find
the resolution and the detection limits
to be very comparable between the two we
find the automation level much higher
with capillary electrophoresis and
that's been our main driving force so
from my perspective they're both
complementary technologies as I
mentioned IT works through subtraction
you know fixation works through addition
however for our laboratory because of
the volume we went with capillary zone
electrophoresis it handles a better
volume it's much more automated I will
say that I actually queried my text and
said what would you think if we moved
back to gel electrophoresis and they
threatened to kill me my texts are
extremely happy with this technology but
everybody's lab is different your choice
of methodology will depend on your
volume and your mix of material the
capillary zone electrophoresis is also
very good for hemoglobin electrophoresis
which it's our frontline instrument for
that as well
and with that I will take any questions
from the audience and thank you for your
attention
Thank You dr. hood for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A
if you have a question you'd like to ask
dr. hood please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is in what is an instance
is we fixing to gel immuno fixation from
capillary immuno typing appropriate the
only instance which I automatically
reflex to gelling in a fixation from
capillaries own immunity are cases where
I have a light chain that is restricted
is monoclonal but I don't have a
matching heavy chain abnormality in
these instances I go to jail and you
know fixation to rule out an IG d or IgE
monoclonal protein I know some
laboratories will put out a caveat
saying we have light chain restricted
say lambda light chain we can't prove
whether there is an IgE or IG d heavy
chain associated with it in other
instances if I've just got a day of
unsureness about me
I will reflex to an immuno fixation
those are usually small very indistinct
abnormalities and currently right now we
run less than 5% of refluxing to a metal
fixation next what are the
additional advantages to numeral typing
over a needle fixation well the pride
advantage is the level of automation
that's present with capillary zone
electrophoresis you can load any number
of patient specimens that you have the
throughput is quite good that eight
specimens an hour at the same time you
don't have to worry whether you're gonna
have to run a second gel because the
number of specimens or do you have to
hold cases over to the next day because
you've exceeded the number of slots
available on a gel so for us that's the
level of automation and combination with
the throughput of the instrument next
are you afraid of or have you missed
small clinically significant bands well
I think every pathologist is afraid
they've missed something sometime during
their career I feel confident that we
have not missed clinically significant
small bands in part because we use other
pieces of information to help us in our
decision-making so you can look for hypo
gamma globulin emia which Mandic eight
the presence of light chain disease you
can also go into your lab information
systems and see if other testing has
been done for instance serum free cap
and lambda light chain whose results can
help you I think also with the
experience I feel more and more
confident in my ability not to miss an
abnormal specimen now have I ever missed
something that's a question you can
never answer because we never quite know
what it is we don't know so in this
instance we don't know what we've missed
next
I would like to once again thank dr.
hood for his presentation do you have
any final comments my only final comment
would be obviously we're very pleased
with the system that we have in place
there are any individuals in the region
that would like to come in and see how
we run our capillaries own laboratory
we'd be more than welcome more than
happy to walk into our laboratory thank
you thank you once again I would also
like to thank our sponsors sabia for
making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 2018
don't receive an email from lab roots
letting you know in this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye